Democrats combust over pro-life laws
sweeping the country
president Trump presents his new
immigration plan and we checked the
mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show guys we made it it's a
Friday it's here we're almost to the
weekend John wick 3 comes out this
weekend that's all that matters
also Game of Thrones finale on Sunday I
mean let's be honest that that's what
everybody is looking forward to this
weekend right ok but we'll get to all
the actual news in just one second first
let's talk about that coffee that you've
been drinking I guess when you open your
bathroom up to anybody you run the risk
of stumbling across a needle or two at
least that's the case in some of our
nation's coffee shops unfortunately for
coffee without the needles stick to
black rifle coffee if you are less
interested in the social justice warrior
mentality of your coffee company and
more interested in quality coffee you
might instead want to check out black
rifle coffee founded by former Special
Ops vets black rifle delivers the best
roasts to order coffee directly to your
door this guarantees you're getting
fresh premium coffee with every single
order and black rifles coffee club makes
things supremely easy just pick your
blend in the amount you want black rifle
ships your coffee directly to your door
every month hassle-free no lines no
running out just great coffee shipped
direct to your door every single month
plus when you join their coffee club you
will receive discounts and offers that
are not available to other customers
when you drink black rifle coffee you
are supporting a company that gives back
to veteran and first responder causes
serves coffee and culture to those who
truly love America I know the founders
of black rifle coffee they are awesome
dudes it is a fantastic company go check
them out right now no needles no crime
just bold flavor freedom 20% off your
first purchase when you shop at black
rifle coffee calm slash Ben that is
black rifle coffee calm slash Ben for
20% off your first purchase that's black
rifle coffee calm slash Ben go check
them out right now okay so pro-life
legislation sweeping the country we have
this Alabama bill which is still
generating most of the headlines I think
the reason for that is because it is the
strictest bill also because the left has
an unusual dislike for the state of
Alabama they see the state of Alabama as
retrograde and so they feel it's easy to
humiliate as opposed to say the more
urbane Missouri or Louisiana they're a
bunch of states that have passed
heartbeat bills at this point Ohio has
passed one Michigan is working on one
Louisiana Kentucky Mississippi Missouri
all of these places are passing pro-life
bills right now we talked yesterday
about the strategy what the strategy
should be from a legal point of view but
there is very little question from a
pro-life perspective that all of this is
great stuff
that if you are pro-life what you want
is more of these bills that help protect
the life of the innocent unborn now the
left is going berserk over all of this
it's funny left in October Zurich / New
York's law which suggested that abortion
should be available even when a baby's
head is coming into the birth canal
that's no problem but when you talk
about banning abortion passed the fetal
heartbeat or when you talk about life
beginning at conception then people
start to go a little crazy and they
start to make kind of ridiculous
arguments they try to suggest that a
right to life that is inherent in the
nature of being a human being that if
you support that right to life you also
have to support you also have to support
cradle to grave healthcare for example
or you also have to adopt every kid who
is not aborted just bad arguments
cropping up everywhere we're gonna go
through a few of those bad arguments
today because these bad arguments are
becoming more and more common media are
pressing forward with all of them CNN
had a guest in Coates is talking about
the Alabama abortion law Laura coats
should former federal prosecutor which
of course makes her a constitutional
expert and she says that the Alabama
abortion law is unconstitutional because
there is a right to abortion in the
Constitution they actually have to have
an appellate process it'll make its way
up to the courts before it's actually
implemented at the lower levels at the
circuit court levels to figure out if
there will be a lower court to say that
this is actually constitutional which
frankly as it's written right now is not
constitutional according to the roe v
wade precedent because that is a
framework of trimesters it relies on
that old adage of your rights and remind
begin and the state cannot intrude on a
woman's right to have that private
conversation until the fetus is viable
outside the womb the courts have looked
at this issue and thought the trimester
framework works okay actually that's not
what the courts have found what the
courts have done is they reverse that in
Planned Parenthood versus Casey it was
Roe versus Wade that instituted the
trimester framework Planned Parenthood
versus Casey changed that trimester
framework just speaking in terms of
constitutional law to the undue burden
standard which says that you cannot
unduly burden a woman's ability to get
an abortion
that undue burden standard has allowed
for example federal legislation like the
partial-birth abortion ban Act okay with
all of that said is there anything in
the Constitution that guarantees a right
to an abortion of course not
of course not the founders would been
astounded at such an idea the idea of a
right to abortion in the Constitution is
a perversion of the Constitution rooted
in precisely the same sort of logic that
allowed the Dred Scott decision to go
forward the two worst decisions in the
history of the Supreme Court the Dred
Scott decision which decided that black
people were not people under the
Constitution of the United States and
the Roe versus Wade decision which
decided that unborn people are not
people under the Constitution of the
United States both of those decisions
are bad both of those decisions are
wrong and both are rooted in an
interpretation of the constitution
called substantive due process now you
may think to yourself that term seems
like it is self-defeating process and
substance are not the same thing how can
you have a substantive due process but
what that means is that we don't like
the way that the process goes not the
process itself we don't like that the
law that is being applied is being
applied at all and therefore we are
going to pretend that it is not done
through a proper process so normally
what due process of law means is that
you have to have for example a jury
trial for a criminal for a criminal
matter or it means that you have to go
through a legal process if you are going
to remove someone's property from them
it does not mean however that the courts
have a say on the status of the law
itself that is being implemented so for
example let's say that there's a law
that says that you are not allowed to
steal somebody else's car and then
there's a product you steal somebody
else's car you go through a due process
and we jail you the courts do not have
the ability to say we don't like the law
that says you can't steal somebody
else's car because that is not due
process that doesn't make any sense the
process itself is do you just don't like
the substance of law what the court
didn't Dred Scott is they said no no no
we are now going to use the phrase due
process to suggest that the substance of
the law itself is wrong and thus for
example you have to return black black
former slaves escaped slaves back to
their masters which was the ruling in
Dred Scott or under roe v wade
substantive due process means that you
have to go through a process by which we
mean you have to allow women have an
abortion there's nothing in the
Constitution that suggests all of this
and you can tell that from the language
of the Supreme Court cases that are on
point on this first what happened is
that the Supreme Court declared a right
to privacy in the case called Griswold
versus Connecticut which was about
whether a state could have laws on the
books that banned the sale of
contraceptives to non married couples
now I think such laws are incredibly
stupid however there's nothing in the
Constitution that guarantees a right
against the state with regard to the
sale of contraceptives there is just
nothing there obviously the Constitution
does not speak on this the Supreme Court
however in that case declared that there
was a broad right to privacy created by
quote-unquote emanations and penumbra's
from the first third fourth fifth and
ninth amendments in Griswold versus
Connecticut you know even if you believe
there is a right to privacy that
emanates and creates penumbra's whoo-hoo
okay even if you believe that crap then
that's still that right to privacy still
would not encompass a very non private
decision to go to a third-party provider
to snuff out a third party human life
which would be the baby's life in this
particular case in Roe the Supreme Court
didn't even bother with the legal
analysis they just said the right to
privacy whether it be founded in the
Fourteenth Amendments concept of
personal liberty and restrictions upon
state action or as we feel it is in the
ninth amendments reservation of Rights
to the people is broad enough to
encompass a woman's decision whether or
not to terminate her pregnancy this is
completely absurd obviously the 14th
amendment explicitly guarantees a right
to life not just a right to Liberty so
does the Fifth Amendment's the
Constitution the Fifth Amendment to the
Constitution reads in relevant part that
no person no person shall be deprived of
life liberty or property without due
process of law well it seems to me like
being deprived of life because two
people have met in a room and decided
that you should be deprived of life is
in fact a deprivation of life without
due process of law that's not a
substance even due process argument that
is a due process due process argument
there's been no defense attorney for the
baby there's been no trial nothing now
the people who are declaring this
phantom rights privacy it is worthy of
note that we have now reached a bizarre
point in America's constitutional
history where the same people who
declare phantom rights to health care
phantom rights to abortion will stay
openly that there is no right to bear
arms that the right to freedom of
religion ought to be dramatically
curtail so that you can only practice
religion in your own home if they
and political speech should be curtailed
you shouldn t able to spend money on
Elections right the same people who are
willing to override virtually every
right that is guaranteed in the
Constitution of the United States in
favor of a centralized to top-down
government that controls how we live
those same people are finding new rights
in the Constitution that never existed
before it's really really absurd and roe
versus wade in its establishment of the
quote-unquote right to abortion has to
overlook the basic obvious fact that
there is no definition of personhood
other than human life there is no other
definition what the Left likes to do is
they say well you know there's human
life and then there's personhood just
like there's sex and then there's gender
and just like gender for the left the
notion of personhood is completely
malleable it changes from time to time
the status of the person changes from
time to time and that means that the
unborn person does not have rights
because maybe personhood is dependent on
heartbeat maybe personhood is dependent
on viability and that's why justice
Blackmun writes in Roe vs. Wade
we need not resolve the difficult
question of when life begins when those
trained in the respective disciplines of
Medicine's philosophy and theology are
unable to arrive at any consistent
consensus the judiciary in this point in
the development to man's knowledge is
not in a position to speculate as to the
answer now we all know when life begins
and Blackmun even right here is
conflating the beginning of life with
personhood but then the left will
separate that as well you know it's it
is human life but it is not personhood
that that obviously is silly talk it's
silly talk which is why Peter Singer who
at least is a philosophically consistent
wild left ethicist at Princeton
University acknowledged in The Scotsman
in 2009 quote opponents will respond
that abortion is by its very nature
unsafe for the fetus they point out that
abortion kills a unique living human
individual that claim is difficult to
deny at least if by human we mean member
of the species Homo sapiens which is why
at least Peter Singer is consistent
enough to acknowledge that he's fine
with killing a newborn baby after birth
he says killing a newborn baby is never
equivalent to killing a person that is a
being who wants to go on living because
his standard for personhood is a person
who has rationality autonomy and
self-consciousness which would rule out
pretty much anybody who is mentally ill
in a coma or hooked up to an iron lung
now the bad arguments continue along
these lines Liz Planck was a feminist
feminist thinker she tweeted something
out that is pretty
absurd we'll get to that in just one
second first it is spring the time of
year when seeds grow into flowers and
you grow up financially at least your
family needs protection if something
happens to you that means you need life
insurance thankfully policy genius makes
it easy to get that financial security
without the growing pains policy genius
is the easy way to buy life insurance
online from just two minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers and
find your best price once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape no
Commission's no hidden fees just
financial protection and peace of mind
no strings attached policy genius
doesn't just simplify life insurance
they also make it easy to compare and
buy home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance so the next time
you stop to smell the roses pull out
your phone head on over to policy genius
calm policy genius spring is here kick
it off by nipping life insurance in the
bud that's policy genius calm go check
it out right now policy should use be a
responsible adult make sure that your
family is taken care of in case god
forbid something should happen to you
and while you're at it well while you're
at it go take care of your home
insurance auto insurance disability
insurance go check them out at policy
genius calm the best way to get life
insurance right this very moment you can
do it right now my pause what you're
doing go do it policy genius.com okay so
Liz Planck is a feminist who had another
relatively insane suite this debate
drives people off the wall I mean it
makes them totally crazy because once if
you believe that your way of life and
your freedom is predicated on the
ability to murder another human life to
get rid of another human life and then
somebody informs you that that is
morally wrong you're going to be
insulted because your entire logic is
rooted in a falsehood and when you
realize that that falsehood is a
falsehood you you start to find that
disquieting and insulting I'm sure that
there were slave owners in the South who
spent their entire lives thinking I'm a
good person while holding slight
virtually all people think that they are
good people
probably they felt I'm a good person
these black folks aren't actually people
these black folks are property and then
they were informed no those black folks
are in fact people and you are
mistreating them and you are being evil
I am sure that was a disquieting notion
to those people if you spend your entire
life dehumanizing another group of
people and then you are informed that
this is immoral and wrong and you have
taken it to your heart that this is the
essence of your right as a human being
is to eat dehumanize this other form of
human life I can understand why people
are upset
it is not an implicit as an explicit
critique of your moral standing no
wonder people are getting upset so Liz
Planck was a feminist at feminists
tabulous over at Twitter she says behind
millions of successful men is an
abortion they don't regret getting with
their partner
I urge men to go beyond solidarity and
talk about how they've personally
benefited from abortion rights to not
because it's the right thing for you to
do but because it's true now imagine the
insane evil of this statement because
there are millions of successful men who
have been able to get away with having a
more successful career by not having to
support a child that they helped to
create they should be speaking out in
favor of abortions who cuz hey
successful career man based on the fact
that I knocked some woman up and then
she went and killed the baby I mean and
that that's great for me Elliot broidy
did this right he tried to pay off say
the former head of the RNC Finance
Committee he tried to pay off a porn
star that he had slept with and gotten
pregnant and we all thought wow that's
really quite terrible isn't it but
according to his playing it's really not
that terrible you know his success was
conditioned on the fact that he was
willing to get rid of that baby and if
he got maybe his life would be better
now if the baby had been gotten rid of
it's amazing you know who should really
be thankful one particular CNN
commentator will talk about it in just
one second so CNN's Jeffrey Toobin is
the legal analyst over at CNN and what
it's funny people will say that men men
should not speak about abortion unless
unless those men happen to agree with
the leftist perspective on abortion you
know it seems to me should really not
speak about abortion men who have a
personal stake in the killing of babies
if you have a personal stake in getting
rid of a third party life for your own
political convenience it seems to me
this should probably invalidate your
perspective on the issue I think that
you are not a good spokesperson for this
issue so you know it's not a good
spokesperson for this issue Jeffrey
Toobin who is the legal commentator on
CNN hears jeffrey toobin getting very
very angry about abortion law then i
would tell you a brief story about
jeffrey toobin which explains perhaps
why he's not a reliable commentator on
this issue Donald Trump said in the
third debate with Hillary Clinton if I
get two or more appointments to the
Supreme Court automatically that's the
word he used automatically roe v wade
will be overturned and I think the
president was exactly right
roe v-- wade is gone and every woman in
Alabama who gets pregnant is gonna be
forced to give birth soon and that's
gonna be true in Alabama it's gonna be
true in Missouri it's gonna be true
probably in Georgia and that's what the
law is because that's what the
presidential election was about in part
okay well did Jeffrey Toobin very upset
about this now what I say the Jeffrey
Toobin opinion means less than nothing
to me it means less than nothing to me
why well let's flashback
all the way to 2010 New York Daily News
quote Sunday could be a bittersweet
first Mother's Day for Casey Greenfield
Greenfield is a pretty ginger-haired
yale-educated lawyer and writer who last
march gave birth to a love child the
baby's father is married CNN star and
best-selling New Yorker writer Jeffrey
Toobin ever since we broke the news of
her pregnancy Casey has remained silent
about the baby drama but now some of her
friends are fed up with what they claim
is less than gallant behavior on subin's
part Greenfield now 36 was in her 20s
when she fell for tube in now 49 even
though he was wed to amy Mackintosh the
Harvard sweetheart he'd met in 1986 and
who gave him two children Jeff and Casey
saw each other on and off for years had
one source she was married to someone
else for two years after her divorce she
started seeing Jeff again he said he was
gonna leave his wife for her but by then
Casey had begun to distrust him she
suspected he had several other
mistresses in 2008 when Greenfield
became pregnant and when she told Tube
in the news he offered her money if
she'd have an abortion says a source he
also allegedly offered to pay for her to
have another child later via a sperm
donor
when Casey wouldn't have an abortion
Jeff told her she was going to regret it
that she shouldn't expect any help from
him claims another source Greenfield
underwent a risky DNA test while
pregnant but Toobin didn't provide his
sample and stopped talking to her
according to sources on the day she gave
birth Greenfield emailed Toobin inviting
him to meet his son Rory a source said
Toobin did not reply to Ben ultimately
cooperated with the DNA test that proved
he was Rory's dad in February a
Manhattan Family Court judge ordered him
to pay child support when he refused to
pay the full amount say the sources
green fields lawyer threatened to notify
his employers and garnish his wages
Toobin then paid up too but now sees the
13 month-old look like air his wife Amy
comes with them to the parks as a source
he said to have asked to spend every
other week day with Rory
Casey isn't convinced he really wants to
serve as a dad's as a friend it may be
legal maneuvering it's been a
a couple of years for Casey says a
friend she's a single mom but her family
couldn't be more supportive the baby is
such a joy for everyone and that last
line is really the one that matters the
baby is such a joy for everyone but
Jeffrey Toobin may in fact have a little
bit of a stake in the abortion debate
because after all he wanted to abort a
love child for his own successful career
so according to Liz Planck he should
actually be on the front lines of
defending abortion obviously it would
have made his career so much easier if
that baby had never lived that had been
so much better for him if you can't see
the moral problem here folks I don't
know what to tell you meanwhile
Democrats are upping the ante
the Colorado Secretary of State has now
come forward and said that she wants to
forbid employee travel to Alabama after
this abortion ban and we've seen similar
stuff after North Carolina passed a law
that was designed to protect business's
ability to have separate bathrooms for
men and for women there are a bunch of
states that said well we won't let our
employees travel over to North Carolina
well now they're doing the same routine
with Alabama yes I am sure that Alabama
will simply wither in the absence of
Colorado state employees flying
therefore bureaucratic conferences
according to the Denver Post employees
of the Colorado Secretary of State's
office won't be traveling to Alabama
anytime soon in a mostly symbolic
gesture yeah no kidding Secretary of
State General Griswold announced new
restrictions Thursday forbidding her
staff from traveling to the state that
just adopted the most stringent
anti-abortion law in the nation the ban
is on work-related travel for employees
of the Secretary of State's office
whereas weld also called on the election
center a non-profit training center for
election officials to relocate their
training out of Alabama I do wonder if
this is constitutional considering the
privileges and immunities clause is it
constitutional to tell your own
employees they are not allowed to visit
a state on work-related business because
you don't like that state also just as a
general rule is this really good for the
country I disagree with all the policies
in my native state California I think
our policies suck but I still live there
and I think it's worthwhile for people
to visit there we're still all Americans
these are all debates worth having you
know we are moving dramatically toward
the point where we can't live together
anymore
you have restaurants that are turning
people away on the basis of politics you
have people who are saying they won't
visit other states based on state
legislative
and we're talking we're not talking
about state legislative policy for
example that says that black people and
white people have to have separate water
fountains we're talking about state
legislative policy that says for example
that you shouldn't be able to kill an
unborn human life and womb or that men
and women should have separate bathrooms
if this is what we're coming to it seems
like we're cruisin for a bruisin as a
country a spokeswoman for the Colorado
governor Jared Paulus said he is not
considering following Griswolds lead but
he did denounce the new law obviously
because all Democrats are going to Cory
Booker went further he said this is an
assault on human dignity the sort of
Orwellian language being used by
Democrats here is pretty astonishing so
it's an assault on human dignity not to
be able to kill a human life in the womb
that's the assault on human dignity is
really that you're not allowed to end
another thing's life that's that's
that's really I think an assault on it
here's Cory Booker the the Spartacus
like senator from New Jersey extreme
this is it's it literally says in the
cases of rape and incest that a woman
still is still illegal for a doctor to
perform an abortion and so this is
outrageous this is an assault on human
rights human dignity freedom to control
your body which has been a fight going
on from the founding of this country and
I I cannot in any way sit comfortably
while this is going on and this is
something this is a time in American
history that mandates all of us to stand
up and get involved in this fight
Wow he can't sit silently as women are
not allowed to kill unborn human life I
mean he hid in a state that he doesn't
actually run my goodness what would
happen men in a second I want to talk a
little bit more about constitutional
rights and left's of perspective on
constitutional rights why what we're
actually talking about with regard to
Alabama and the nature of constitutional
rights is danger for the dangerous for
the future of the country first let's
talk about your hiring now I know you've
got a lot of great employees but you
need better employees or you need more
great employees well the best way to do
that is to head on over to zip recruiter
com slash daily wire zip recruiter is
fantastic it sends your job to over 100
of the web's leading job boards they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and then invites
to apply to your job as applications
come in zip recruiter analyzes each one
and spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day I'll admit it now I've been trying
to use zip recruiter for years to get
rid of Michel moles but we've never
actually posted an unzip recruiter to
get rid of Michel moles which is why we
haven't been able to do so as soon as I
do that I know we will find someone
superior to Michel moles I mean that
that's because if recruiter is also
great and also because if I throw a rock
into a crowd and hit somebody that
person would be better than Michael
moles right now my listener can my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that zip
recruiter comm slash Dai ly WI re zip
recruiter comm slash daily Wire zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire go check them out right now zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire so the
left's perspective on the Constitution
is that the Constitution is just
supposed to give them whatever they want
and it's never supposed to take away
something that they like that is their
perspective on the Constitution of the
United States Tim Ryan who is a congress
person from Ohio who's now running for
president another one of these quixotic
campaigns he was on NBC News yesterday
and he's openly saying that he would
have a litmus test when it comes to
Supreme Court justices would they uphold
roe v wade now it's pretty amazing
because the left has said we should
never have litmus tests when it comes to
Supreme Court justices we should never
be able to ask a Supreme Court justice
how they would rule on Roe vs. Wade for
example I disagree with that I'm glad
for this sort of this sort of
transparency from Tim Ryan he wants to
ask justices straight up if they would
overrule roe versus wade one of the
worst argued and and reasoned
constitutional decisions in American
history here is explaining the
Constitution should basically be a hacky
sack for him to kick around if you're
president would you essentially have a
Roe litmus test for judges yeah yeah I
would most definitely this is not
something to be messed with
pure and simple not at this at this
moment in history people could try to
dance around it I will you know I will
have someone who will protect roe v wade
no question about it okay so you know
again Democrats see the Constitution as
a way of protecting crap they like they
do not see it as an actual document that
embed
certain values and that's why it's funny
you see so many people on the Left who
have been cheering New Zealand so in the
aftermath of Christchurch shooting the
evil terrorist attack on a mosque in New
Zealand the Prime Minister Jacinda R
Dern was pushing all sorts of supremely
harsh anti gun regulations and she was
also criminalizing by the way even
downloading the manifesto of the shooter
which seems like a tremendous violation
of basic free speech principles even
though I've said publicly I don't think
anybody should read that piece of crap
and I hope the guy burns in hell
in any case New Zealand Prime Minister
Jacinda R Dern she said she doesn't
understand the u.s. and what's amazing
is this is being passed around by folks
on the left like yeah I don't get it
either I don't get it either
here is just end our turn saying she
doesn't understand why the u.s. is
taking so long on its gun regulations
over 110 mass shootings in the United
States since 1982 you know even
President Obama couldn't do that in the
United States after the massacre of
children at Sandy Hook you can draw a
line and say that that does not mean
that you need access to military-style
semi-automatic weapons and assault
rifles you do not and New Zealanders by
and large absolutely agreed with that
position Australia experienced a
massacre and changed their laws New
Zealand had its experience and changed
its laws to be honest with you I do not
understand the United States right she
doesn't understand the United States
because we do have a Constitution that
embeds particular values the fact that
there are so many people are left to
cheer this that our journey from her
perch as Prime Minister change the laws
overnight that explains why we do have a
constitution which is to protect the
American people from the violation of
the rights including the unborn from
violations of their rights and now
meanwhile President Trump has presented
a new immigration plan the immigration
plan is generally directed at legal
immigration systems who want a
merit-based immigration system and he
also wants to strengthen border
protections now the Left says this is
not enough obviously the New York Times
editorial board is very upset because
Trump didn't say that he's going to
reinsure on daca the deferred action for
childhood arrivals program that protects
the so-called dreamers people who
arrived in the United States as children
or teenagers and have been here for
years
now the reason Trump doesn't mention
that is because that is his negotiation
point Democrats if he simply lays out
you know what my goal is to legalize
daca then the minute that he says
that Democrats are gonna say okay how
about we take that and none of the rest
all right this is how deal-making is
done you say what you want and then you
know what the other person wants they
don't want to give you something so you
say I'm gonna withhold the thing you
want until I give you well I'm gonna
hold withhold the thing you want until
you give me what I want right mean
that's how I trade works if Donald Trump
were to say here are all the things I
want including to reinsure and zakah
Democrats would simply say okay fine so
what are you waiting for reinsuring
Dhaka and then we'll talk Trump doesn't
want to do that that's his goal his goal
is to have a negotiation here so
President Trump gave an address in the
Rose Garden unveiling his plan to create
a fair modern and lawful system of
immigration for the United States he
points out the Democrats by contrast are
proposing open borders lower wages in
lawless chaos which seems to me at this
point a fairly good description of what
Democrats are doing considering they
don't even want to fund ice - that's in
the department Homeland Security with
the beds necessary to house people
crossing the border illegally pending
legal action there's president Trump
explaining we must implement an
immigration system that will allow our
citizens to prosper for generations to
come
today we are presenting a clear contrast
Democrats proposing open borders lower
wages and frankly lawless chaos we are
proposing an immigration plan that puts
the jobs wages and safety of American
workers first okay so all of this is
correct Democrats unfortunately are not
treating the immigration issue with
sufficient seriousness President Trump
also says we need to get rid of the
random lottery that decides who gets to
become an American he says that's a
really dumb policy it is a really dumb
policy there is no reason it should be
randomized we should be able to look at
the pool of immigrants and decide who
best serves America's interests we are a
country with borders now I am
libertarian personally on immigration so
long as there is no welfare state so
here my here are my conditions on
immigration to the United States no
taking advantage of welfare also you
should have some skillset that is going
to add to the United States so that you
don't come in and are unemployed also
you should be willing to assimilate now
the only reason again that you should
not be that you should have some skill
set is because
in my view that that is necessary in a
state that does have a welfare benefit
to it you know back in the early 20th
century they were effectively no welfare
benefits and this drew a crowd of people
who were very risk seeking coming to the
United States wanting to assimilate
learning English assimilating to
American values and then going and
working really hard assimilation in the
United States today is a little bit
different because people are coming in
there are tremendous state benefits that
are available there's bilingual
education in many places around the
United States all of this draws a
different not necessarily worse in every
way but a different pool of people
obviously when President Trump says why
as a sovereign country should we have a
random selection of people who come into
the country it's stupid he is correct
about this currently 66 percent of legal
immigrants come here on the basis of
random chance they're admitted solely
because they have a relative in the
United States and it doesn't really
matter who that relative is another 21
percent of immigrants are issued either
by random lottery or because they are
fortunate enough to be selected for
humanitarian relief
random selection is contrary to American
values and blocks out many qualified
potential immigrants from around the
world who have much to contribute ok
this of course is exactly right this is
exactly right the fact that that we have
to select people who come in as opposed
to random selection is obviously corrupt
Trump concludes by saying immigration
has to be based in merit this is silly
why are we not doing a merit-based
system obviously our proposal fulfills
our sacred duty to those living here
today while ensuring America remains a
welcoming country to immigrants joining
us tomorrow and we want immigrants
coming in we cherish the open door that
we want to create for our country but a
big proportion of those immigrants must
come in through merit and skill
okay so all of this is true now in a
second I'm gonna show you how Democrats
can't even be reasonable about all of
this there is a deal to be made
Democrats hate Trump so much that
they're not going to make the deal they
think Trump is hated so much that they
never have to make a deal we'll talk
about that in just a second first you
have to go and subscribe at daily wire
comm when you do you get so many
wonderful things for $9.99 a month you
get a subscription to this show that
means that you get two additional hours
of this show every single day it is just
fantastic you get to do it on demand you
can watch it from your desk at work
while you pretend to do work like all
sorts of great stuff also you get extra
access so our Sunday special comes out
on Saturday for you plus we have
questions that we ask behind the paywall
that you don't get unless you are a
subscriber you get to ask questions as I
say we're doing the mailbag today got to
ask questions in the mailbag all of that
is awesome when you spend $99 a year you
also get this boom very greatest in all
beverage vessels the leftist tiers hot
or cold tumbler how great is this
beverage vessel how great is it it can
be used to nourish babies it is that
glorious time of the week where we give
a shout out to a daily wired subscriber
today Isiah Murillo on instagram has
done the one thing every parent knows to
do which is give your tiny adorable baby
a leftist years tumblr instead of a
bottle this baby by this is freaking
cute that is a cute baby in this photo
baby summary is taking a big sip of some
sweet sweet leftist tears and looking
just adorable doing it the baby is so
cute oh my goodness
Isaiah writes behold the greatest of all
beverage vessels indeed it is Isaiah
indeed it is fantastic picture thank you
to baby son ray and I say it for your
support man that that that's the winner
so far we had a bunch of great pictures
come in that baby is it so I love babies
the baby is adorable okay so go check us
out also at YouTube and iTunes we were
the second most downloaded podcast in
all of America which means all of the
world last month make us number one by
going to youtube and itunes and
subscribing and leaving us a review we
always appreciate it we're the largest
fastest core and conservative podcast
and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so it's amazing president Trump proposes
a merit-based immigration proposal and
the Democrats like nope no merit
we don't want merit we just want
whomever that matter now that is bad
policy just on its face if I say to you
you know you run a business and you want
the best people which is why I should
have zip recruiter for example you want
the best people and you're like no I
don't I just want whoever walks through
that door first I'm gonna say well your
business gonna be bankrupt pretty
quickly or if you have relatives and
some of them are criminals and some of
them are not you're going to pick and
choose who you want to invite to the
family reunion Nancy Pelosi however says
standards are bad no more standards it's
condescending stop it to brief the
members we always see what they have to
say but I want to just say something
about the word that they use merit it is
really a condescending word they're
saying family is without merit are they
saying most of the people have ever come
to the United States in the history of
our country are without merit because
they don't have an engineering degree
and certainly we want to attract the
best in our country to our country and
that includes many people from any parts
of society ok so the fact that that she
says that merit is very bad is amazing
amazing there's no inherent merit and
being somebody's relative are you I'm
against legacy admissions to colleges
for example I think that you should have
to merit to get in Nancy Pelosi is now
standing against merit merit is
condescending that's an amazing
statement
my favorite Nancy Pelosi statement about
Trump's immigration plan though is this
one where she explains every illegal
immigrant has a spark of divinity now
that is a hundred percent true that does
not answer the question as to what our
migration policy should be it means you
shouldn't treat people in humanely it
doesn't mean we have to let everybody in
by Nancy Pelosi says every illegal
immigrant has a spark of divinity unborn
children know every illegal immigrant
yes
also abortion on demand you can kill
babies on demand as long as they're in
the womb and every legal immigrant thus
has a right to stay in the United States
because of the spark of divinity I'm
going to need her to explain we've
always said there's it gets to be more
of a humanitarian crisis the more that
Republican the
administration I won't paint all the
Republicans with this nor the
administration acts in the shameful way
not consistent with our faith with our
beliefs that every person is has dignity
and worth that every person has a spark
of divinity is in them that we need to
respect and that we have that spark of
divinity that we need to act upon ok so
again it's the language here it's
amazing it's when babies know spark of
divinity illegal immigrants yes spark
how about they everybody has a spark of
divinity and then we can deal with
migration policy but migration policy is
not you get to kill the illegal
immigrant unlike baby policy which
apparently is you get to kill the baby
as often as you want okay time for some
mail bag let's mail bag it up a little
bit so today's mail bag Josiah says
heaven Jaime Metzl has discussed the
idea of genetic modification in this
process around 15 female eggs would be
fertilized to help one pick the
genetically superior human of course the
eggs not picked would be discarded is
there a scientific argument against this
my fear is that oftentimes morals tend
to collapse when things become expedient
thanks Josiah I'm not in favor of the
use of in vitro fertilization that ends
with the discarding of fertilized eggs
of embryos in fact there have been
questions about this in Alabama people
talking about why are you not protecting
the fertile I'm in favor of protecting
the fertilized eggs that are outside the
womb they don't have to be in the womb
to be incipient human life and thus
worthy of protection Greg says hey Ben
big fan here most of you views I line
with but as a classical liberal I simply
cannot agree with you on pro-life laws
the question however is not a debate
over abortion talking points which have
been debated ad nauseam by both sides my
question is why do we not concede xx
moral equivalency in terms of killing
animals I'm mostly talking about the
fight against inhumane killing and
torture of animals and slaughterhouses
beating pigs and cattle senseless
disembowelling them without anesthetic
for example as I'm sure you're aware of
luring thousands of dolphins into a tiny
Cove in Japan and stabbing them brutally
to death with Spears are we not all
creatures of God we all play a role in
the planet's ecosystem this kind of
cruelty is unconscionable where do we
draw that line and why is this okay
but aborting an embryo with no nervous
system brain or brain stem is a grave
moral sin thanks Ben love the show I'll
always be a subscriber I appreciate it
Greg so the basic answer here is that
human life is worth more than other
types of life human life is worth more
than other types of life and it is not a
matter of the stage of development of
the human
life human life is inherently worth more
because human beings are endowed with
individual human characteristic and
members of the species Homo sapiens and
thus deserve greater protections they
will have the capacity to reason they do
have the capacity if they do not that is
that is a shortcoming but that does not
invalidate their membership in the human
species humans are worth more is the
short answer humans have a soul from a
religious perspective from a
non-religious perspective we all sort of
agree that humans are worth more than
animals otherwise presumably be a Janus
which there are some people who are but
I don't see most people doing that now
as to the mistreatment of animals I will
admit to you that I am ideologically
driven toward vegetarianism or veganism
I have a tough time reconciling being
humane with the eating of animals animal
protein is necessary particularly for
children I hope that we soon develop
substitutes for the killing of animals
for food I think that would be a very
good thing on just the humane level I
will admit to hypocrisy on this I don't
live up to my own standards I haven't
actually tried a vegetarian diet and
that's not specifically out of love of
meat although I really do love meat it
really is more specifically out of
probably convenience but the fact is
that I hear the argument for the humane
treatment of animals and I sort of agree
with it to be frank mark says dear Ben
you mentioned several times about places
such as 4chan H and other sites you have
stated some horrible things are stated
here I agree you have said some
legitimately bad people have posted on
these sites and mill around on these
sites my question is where's the divide
between people posting horrible things
on the internet because they can and
they in a phrase want to watch the world
burn and the people who actually believe
in what they're posting and when should
be treated as such well once you move
away from saying terrible things about
people in evil things and you move into
overt threats of violence or support for
overt threats of violence then you have
crossed a line there is a difference in
American law and every form of common
law between speech and incitement
incitement actually has to incite it has
to be go kill X so what I've seen is on
a chain for example there was this
there's this person who was hanging out
I believe he's on a Chan who was
arrested by the FBI a couple of weeks
ago he was threatening me who's
threatening Donald Jr he was threatening
Jared Kushner and there's an FBI arrest
of this guy I believe he was hanging out
on some of these message boards if I
not mistaken I know that after he was
arrested there were message boards where
people were saying things like next time
just go shoot Shapiro and don't post
about on the message board we all know
why you did it and now I think that you
should probably be monitor for the sake
of safety because you're actively
advocating violence against a specific
another human being with that said I
think the vast majority of the of the
nastiness that I receive and I perceive
an awful lot of it is protected by the
First Amendment should be protected by
the First Amendment
and well I don't think it's harmless to
the public discourse I don't think that
it's something that earns you government
government you know oversight let's see
Jackson says hey Ben what is the logic
behind insider trading being illegal if
I'm able to know secrets about a company
that would make my shares of the company
change why should I not be allowed to
act upon those secrets to my own gain
Thanks love the show well there is a
very solid libertarian case that insider
trading should not be illegal that one
of the benefits of working for the
company is that you should be able to
trade on the insider information and
that actually would create more
transparency in the market because
everyone would just follow whatever the
CEO of the company is doing you'd
actually have quicker transparency to
market attempting to police insider
trading has very largely been a fool's
errand I sort of agreed the libertarian
case larry elder makes this case pretty
eloquently again it should yeah if you
have a privately owned company and
you're involved in the decision-making
of the company you own stock in the
company and your decisions are designed
to raise the stock of the company now I
guess the the case against insider
trading presumably would be let's say
that you're trying to short sell the
company right that you decide that
you're gonna deliberately tank the stock
of your company in order to a publicly
traded company and harm the other
stockholders in order to get all of the
all of the benefit that's not an insider
trading thing though that is a breach of
fiduciary duty and that's a crime in and
of itself so I'm not sure that insider
trading has to be on the table in order
for that to be a crime breaches of
fiduciary duty are in fact financial
fraud and you will go to jail for that
Daniel says hey Ben I'm currently in
Poland on a study abroad trip in which
we are exploring different Holocaust
sites one thing my professor has
continued to bring up is that Jews do
not believe that a child is a life until
it passes through the birth canal I was
wondering if you could provide me with
more context as the actual Jewish
standards on abortion and when it would
be considered acceptable
thank you Dan so there's a rich debate
in Jewish literature about when a
when an unborn human child is considered
a full life
technically it's between two great sages
in Jewish history Rashi and Rambam Rashi
basically suggests that it's not a human
life up to points of birth at least not
not a full it's not fully equated with
the rights of a born human and Rambam
seems to suggest otherwise this home
would in tractate Sanhedrin talks at
length about this particular issue but
when it comes to the laws about abortion
when it comes to whether you're allowed
to abort Judaism is fully pro-life
Judaism is indeed pro-life the basic
rule in Judaism is that there are no
abortions abortions are not allowed
except in the cases where the mother's
life is in danger that is the basic
standard now you sometimes can even go
to a rabbi and you get what's called a
head tear that means that you can get
some sort of leniency but the baseline
standard is this right for the sake of
clarity for the sake of clarity let's
talk about some of the great rabbis for
just a second
the position of virtually all of the
greatest rabbis of the 20th century from
RAV moshe feinstein who considered
abortion murder to rob slo-mo Zalman
arbok who agreed to Rabbi Joseph B
salivate check who also agreed he said
in 1975 to me it is something vulgar
this clamor of the Liberals that
abortion be permitted to rabbi ovadia
yosef he said that abortion is
biblically prohibited past three months
and at least rabbinical e prohibited
before then so this is why I have said
for a very long time the presence of
human life means that this has worth
that does not mean that the worth is
exactly equivalent to the worth of a
five-year-old trial but it does mean
that the life is deserving of the same
protections as a five-year-old child
would receive again rabbis do argue on
the level of exceptions permitted but
even the rabbi's who are considered more
lenient on abortion agree that it is
prohibited if so facto they just
consider more exceptions acceptable but
there is not a single Jewish opinion not
one that supports the mainstream
pro-choice position on abortion which is
that it's the woman choice at any point
in the pregnancy there is no zero zero
Jewish sages have ever backed such an
idea ever ever ever as rabbi Aram
Lichtenstein explained even if we were
to accept that it is indeed a woman's
own body we totally reject the
conception that she can do with it as
she pleases this is a completely anti ha
logic perception ilaha is is merely
Jewish law so all of
this is is you know people who claim
that Judaism is pro-choice are simply
lying about it all the talk about the
the there's a section in Talmud where
talks about the status of the fetus as
being akin to water for the first forty
days well there is a question as to
whether that is talking about the legal
status for purposes of ritual purity and
that's the typical way that it is
explained that cuts in some very
abstruse areas of Jewish law that I
don't frankly have time to go into right
now but suffice to say that just quoting
all of that and then print and then
pretending that that that is dispositive
as to the nature of Jewish law and
abortion is it's a lie it's not true
Kyah says hey man my friend and I had an
argument recently on the issue of trying
to reconcile modern science with some of
the biblical narratives she doesn't
understand how one can fully believe in
Genesis and the Torah and yet also
believe in accepted scientific theories
like evolution or the big bang theory
what's your take on this do you believe
creation actually happened in six days
and if you do how do you reconcile this
with theories like evolution thank you
so much for both massive fans of the
show so there's a great book that I
recommend it on the show would have been
three weeks ago called science what is
it it's by Gerald Schroeder George Erard
Schroeder Gerald Schroeder and his book
is all about reconciling but the Bible
with modern science he's written a bunch
of books on this as the science of God
is the one that I recommended he
specifically talks about the six days
and how six days of Earth time matches
up to the biblical that matches up to
the scientific timeline the idea the Big
Bang absolutely matches up with the
biblical narrative remember that for
most of human history the scientifically
urbane perspective was that was that
universe had always existed would always
continue to exist that that the universe
was eternal and then science moved
toward the Big Bang and scientists were
very upset with this at the time they
thought oh my god this this tends to
sound a lot too much like the Bible it
was it was very disquieting for a lot of
scientists which is why many scientists
have now started to rely on multiple
universes theory Bryan Keating has a
great video for Prager University
talking about the multiple universes
theory and how its unprovable just as
unprovable as the presence of God in the
universe for example as far as the the
creation story the creation narrative
actually matches up quite well with the
with the path of evolution again I
recommend that you check out Gerald
Schroeder's book he talks about this at
length ELISA says hey Ben my name is
ELISA I'm a college student from San
Diego
I wanted to know besides Harvard what
other great law schools are there to
apply to thanks for all you do
big fan well ELISA I mean they're
they're a bunch of great law schools
Yale Law School is a great law school
not as good as Harvard but yells pretty
good University of Chicago has a great
law school Columbia has a great law
school and the reality is that where you
go to law school is much more about
credentialing than about learning the
law it's really a filtering system there
are a lot of great law schools that are
according quote secondary law schools
UCLA is a great law school USC has a
very good law school University of Texas
has a great law school so it depends on
sort of what you want to do Amy says
when making birth control available over
the counter subside the result of
unwanted pregnancies well
birth control is widely available and
that has has done some work in
preventing unwanted pregnancy obviously
it is not done all the work because we
still have nearly a million abortions a
year in the United States Hanks has been
time traveling to Jerusalem in a few
weeks to work on an archaeological dig
outside of Jerusalem do you know of any
sites I should visit while in the city
other than the more well-known sites
like the Western Wall and the Church of
the Holy Sepulchre well they're a bunch
of sites in so his Hezekiah water
tunnels are super cool they're the the
tunnels that were built to withstand
siege from foreign parties and they they
go for hundreds of yards there's there's
a great book called the source by James
missioner where he discusses a lot of
the archaeological sites around
Jerusalem and it really is fantastic he
names a bunch of the sites that are
worthwhile visiting another one that is
absolutely worth while visiting are the
the Kotel tunnels so everybody knows
about visiting the Western Wall but you
should actually go to the tunnels there
are tunnels that dig down the walls of
the the western wall goes down another
thirty feet probably and you can
actually see that you can actually take
the tunnels below the Temple Mount it's
really cool stuff Patrick says hey Ben
love the show you helped me lose my mind
you help me not lose my mind when I'm in
San Diego with the military I've been
having multiple conversations with
friends of mine or way more liberal than
I I tend to a-line very much with you
when discussing the beginning of a human
life who responds to separate DNA 46
chromosomes etc was that doesn't matter
to me I have no idea how to respond to
this besides agreeing to disagree well I
mean facts don't matter to me means the
end of the conversation by the way so do
character attacks if somebody makes a
character attack on you and they are
intent on smearing your character you
have every right not to engage in the
conversation anymore Elijah says hey
huge fan of yours I went as I went as
far as to name my dog after the 30th
President Calvin Coolidge what are your
thoughts on Coolidge is present so I am
generally a big Coolidge fan
I think Coolidge was wildly underrated
I'm very much in favor of chief
executives who don't talk a lot and
don't do a lot and just are there and
that was Coolidge's perspective so I'm
generally a Coolidge guy okay time for
some things I like and then some things
that I hate so things that I like there
is a series on Netflix that is is really
good for the acting the series is called
dead to me
with Christina Applegate and Linda
Cardellini who's been in everything
lately I don't know we're in like the
Linda Cardellini boom right now she's
terrific in it Christina Applegate is
actually probably even better she's
really really good in it but the acting
in the show is great James Marsden is in
it as well
the show is certainly rated R and the
ending of the first season is a little
bit too shy stay woke I don't think woke
is is the proper term but it basically
it dead to me is is sort of the foot
it's sort of just another spin on big
little lies effectively but I enjoyed
big little lies and so I enjoyed dead to
me here's a little bit of the trailer
just heated up at 300 and leave it in
for 35 minutes thanks Karen it's my take
on Mexican lasagna great Jeff and I
can't imagine what you're going through
well it's like if Jeff got hit by a car
and died suddenly and violently
like that well you get that dish back to
me whenever you can
[Music]
welcome to friends of heaven looks like
we have so many people here today and
beauty Jen I hope this isn't weird can I
give you a hug no okay
I lost my fiance 8 weeks ago it's really
seven so the show the show is well
written it's good it's from it's
produced by Will Ferrell and Adam McKay
which is usually a pretty good producing
team again see I live in a world where
I'm happy to recommend the art of others
even if I disagree with them politically
I know this is getting unique out there
but I actually enjoyed the show I think
that it's worth the watch okay other
things that I like today so Bill
DeBlasio is having a rough one no one
knows why he's running I mean he can't
even run his own city and now he wants
to run the country and everybody is
super confused about it so he was being
grilled on Good Morning America didn't
go great for him the tough city we're
hearing it outside some protesters
there's a pole about a month ago
Quinnipiac poll they showed 76% of New
York voters 73% of New York Democrats
say you should run so what should the
rest of the country think when so many
of your fellow New Yorkers are saying
don't run you know I got elected mayor
but 73% of the vote originally
re-elected with 67% of the vote I think
you'd agree that the poll that actually
matters is the election so New Yorkers
have twice said that they want me to
lead them and I think about polling in
general it's not where you start it's
where you end um no no no no no no no so
there's a poll that says would you like
Bill de Blasio to be your mayor that
happens on Election Day and New Yorkers
because many New Yorkers are foolish
when it comes to their votes like yeah
let's get let's have the comi do it that
is not the same thing as let's have him
run the country when I hire a plumber
it's because I think he's gonna be good
at plumbing not because I think he's a
great accountant and even if I hire a
plumber that does not mean that the
plumber I hire for my home is going to
be the one that I hired to do my office
building and what in the world bill de
blasio dude that guy that is it that is
a candidacy that is going nowhere very
very quickly okay time for a couple of
things that I hate
it's very exciting to hear the advocates
of science on the left you know the
people who are very inspired when Bill
Nye sets a globe on fire with a
blowtorch it's very inspiring to hear
those people explain the human life does
not begin at conception it apparently
begins whenever you want it to begin you
know I think that according to that life
begins at 40 human life begins at four
it is four that's what I've been told so
in any case other things about science
they do not like sex like like the fact
that there are sexes they do not like
this thing and this has some predictably
idiotic and terrible results there's a
story from The Associated Press today
it's called the blurred lines a pregnant
man's tragedy tests gender notions okay
couple things one there is no such thing
as a pregnant man does not exist has not
existed will never exist this is a
biological woman who has had hormone
treatments that is what we are talking
about right now so why did something bad
happen because we insist on humoring
people over their self-identification of
gender even in these stupidest possible
circumstances including medical
circumstances so let's say that you
identify you're a woman a biological
woman but you identify as a man when you
go into the doctor wouldn't you want to
tell the doctor that you are a
biological woman that's going to matter
to the diagnosis it's absurd if you have
abdominal pain and you're a you're
listed on your chart is a man and now
you look like a man because you've had
face sculpting surgery and because
you've had hormone treatments and you've
had mastectomy and all of this and
you've done all these things wouldn't
you still want to tell the doctor about
your biology because your abdominal pain
might be something you think that it is
not okay because it might be that your
abdominal pain is coming from say a
uterus that you still have that's
exactly what happened in this story
quote when the man arrived at the
hospital with severe abdominal pains a
nurse didn't consider it an emergency
noting that he was obese and it stopped
taking blood pressure medicines in
reality he was pregnant a transgender
man in labor that was about to end in a
stillbirth no he was not pregnant she
was pregnant and if she had not lied to
the doctors about her biological sex
maybe the baby would still be alive
that's what happened here and for us to
pretend that it's the job of the medical
profession now to scream men for female
disorders or for female problems or to
scream women for prostate disorders is
absurd so 99.99% of the population is
not going
can be divided into sects for purposes
of medical care and now you're telling
me the doctors are gonna have to be
re-educated in their implicit bias so
that if a man walks in they're now going
to do what a pregnancy tests on him and
pee on a stick and when a woman walks
through the door you're gonna make sure
that you give her a prostate exam men
and women are different their biology is
different this is absurd
according to the AP the tragic case
described in Wednesday's New England
Journal of Medicine
points to larger issues about assigning
labels or making assumptions in a
society increasingly confronting gender
variations in sports entertainment and
government but I've been told that
gender and sex are completely malleable
I've been told also that gender in sex
controversially or or conversely are
completely dichotomous that gender has
nothing to do with sex and sex has
nothing to do with gender so if that's
the case why are you writing your gender
on a medical chart if this this idiocy
no it doesn't point to larger issues
about assigning labels it points to the
larger issue about lying about your
biology on a medical chart you dopes the
point is not what happened to this
particular individual but this is an
example of what happens to transgender
people interacting with the healthcare
system says the lead author of this
study dr. Donna streusel of the
University of Michigan Ann Arbor well no
actually the point is what happened to
this particular individual because this
particular individual lied on their
medical chart about their sex he was
rightly classified as a man in medical
records and appears masculine centrum
sa' but that classification threw us off
from considering his actual medical
needs he was not rightly classified as a
man he was rightly classified as a woman
because he was a she because men do not
get pregnant this is so absurd the 32
year old patient told the nurse he was
transgender when he arrived at the
emergency room and his electronic
medical record listed him as male well
if your electronic medical record lists
you as male but doesn't say that you are
transgender and you just told the nurse
that that's a problem maybe you need a
different designation on the electronic
medical records but how you identify in
your head is of no consequence to your
medical treatment the way that this
person should have been diagnosed is is
a woman who is receiving hormone
replacement therapy because that's
biologically what we are talking about
right here hey the stupidity
never ends here's another Associated
Press on this stupidity
so snapchat has a new silly filter okay
it's a new photo filter that allows
users to change into a man or a woman
with the tap of a finger but it's not
necessarily fun and games for
transgender people some say it reduces
their very real and often painful
experiences to Folly okay and the
headline is my gender is not a costume
for trans people gender swap photo
filters are no mere game so let me get
this straight
if you're a woman and you feel that it
is insulting for a man to have surgeries
and then call himself a woman you are a
bigot but if you're a transgender woman
and you feel that it is insulting for a
snapchat filter to show a picture of
what a man would look like as a woman
then you have every right to be offended
oh so I guess so just to just to get
this straight it is cultural
appropriation of transgender people if
there is a snapchat transgender filter
but it is not cultural appropriation of
the opposite sex to say that you are an
actual member of the opposite sex and
then get hormone replacement therapy and
surgery to pretend to be a member of the
opposite sex in biology in appearance oh
oh okay
God got it so solid stuff there
Associated Press thank you for reporting
on our stupid society all righty well I
hope that you have a wonderful joyous
weekend John with recon I've been
pitching John they should pay me I've
been pitching John wick three harder
than anything I pitched in a while
I can't wait to see it I'm gonna
probably go on Monday to see John wick
three with the wife who shockingly is
into the John wick movies I've
indoctrinated her into the ways of John
wick so we'll do that also Game of
Thrones I will give you my final review
of Game of Thrones on Monday because the
finale is Sunday whoo who's excited I
know everybody's hating on Game of
Thrones not me man I'm enjoying this
season I know I'm an upper for once
crazy all right we'll see you here on
Monday have a wonderful weekend I
mention peer oh this is the Ben Shapiro
show
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everyone I'm Alicia Kraus and we
just wrapped a really great episode of
this month's conversation with our very
own Michael Noel's you want to tell
everybody some of the things that we
talked about I think we might have had
one or two questions about abortion I
think maybe that because it's the
biggest news story in the whole kind of
came up that came up we talked about
what it means for the Supreme Court we
talked about 2020 Democrats we talked
about faith and Christianity and most
importantly of all we talked about
cigars and whiskey important topic much
more important than anything else so
head on over daily wire.com also
available on all of our social media
platforms and including the Michael
Noel's page over on iTunes that's right
check it out